like my friends if you do not spend 2018
completely and obsessively around
Facebook and Instagram you will lose
[Music]
Toys R Us did two things over the last
couple decades that make no sense one
very early in the 2000s they outsource
themselves to Amazon they didn't believe
in the Internet
17 years ago so to let Amazon do their
fulfillment which started people getting
used to buying toys on the internet
through an Amazon world but most
importantly they just didn't innovate
you know and when you don't innovate you
die like when you don't change you die
the world passes you by it's the best
example right now of like how in trouble
everybody is if they [ __ ] rest on
their laurels
you know if Toys R Us the dominant Miche
retail leader of a humongous
multi-billion dollar category is
finished what do you think is gonna
happen over the next six years this is a
calm before the social media storm this
is mm all over again the internet came
out it had a lot of hype the market
crashed people couldn't see returns and
people left it borders didn't believe in
it they gave Amazon the infrastructure
there at a business Blockbuster didn't
believe in it they let Netflix come in
and put them out of business social
media has had a lot of hype the last two
years the next three are gonna be soft
because people are not gonna figure out
the ROI and that people can be put out
of business and huge businesses are
gonna blow up and explode and take over
in 2013 14 15 Wow yeah that's what's
happening we have a room of
professionals in this room who say well
my my customers not on Facebook or
Instagram maybe they're on LinkedIn that
is the exact same rationale that Netflix
put blockbuster out of business with
Blockbuster Santa room and they said our
data shows that people like going to our
stores by the way are you really ready
to laugh here's what the report actually
said they liked the experience of going
to our stores because they like the
ability to open and close and read the
back of the DVD cases gets better they
enjoy the serendipity of possibly
running into their neighbor this is what
the report you know by the way that's my
favorite part about reports and data
when you have an agenda you can make a
report do anything you want thank you
and then finally they really like
picking up popcorn on the way out I
don't know about you guys but here is
the experience I like laying naked in my
bed and pressing one [ __ ] button like
social time at the store really like
that's not gonna play out like like it's
just not gonna play out like there's
you'll find other things to do there's
not going to be a single convenience
store in America 20 years
like 7-elevens out of business you're
not gonna go there you're just not
you're gonna get everything within an
hour everything on demand ad hoc at the
lowest possible cost you will not
believe it
we hold the past on a pedestal and we
demonize the future but that's just not
how it works
and this internet thing you're sleeping
on it it's bigger than you think this is
it this is the television and radio of
our society the internet has won there
is no debate you may not like it it
doesn't matter what you think guys
ABC and CBS at ESPN are out of business
it's already over 80 billion dollars you
can sit because I got a rack Bob 80
billion dollars in television
commercials and nobody [ __ ] watches
them over the next three or four to five
years the biggest companies in the world
are gonna understand that that money is
gonna go into the [ __ ] that I just told
you about that's gonna mean the ads that
you're gonna run are gonna go from $4 to
$80 and you're not gonna be able to
compete with coca-cola and BMW so please
heed what I told you take your romance
or your subjective point of view or you
being romantic about how the world used
to be and shove that [ __ ] in the garbage
and get the [ __ ] work one life do
something about it
[Applause]
[Music]